the shootings were captured on live
television
the police's reaction to a prolonged
strike by miners shocked millions of
south africans and left 34 workers dead
10 others had already died in strike
related violence in the week leading up
to the shooting including two police
officers
ten years on some are still calling for
justice
the police are the ones who killed my
brother the miners said police arrived
and shot at them while they were at the
hill
no lufe says she doesn't understand why
her brother was killed
an official inquiry blamed the deaths
and injuries on police tactics and
recommended those responsible be
investigated and prosecuted
so far the government has paid more than
10 million dollars in compensation to
the families of those killed
but dozens of claims are outstanding
including from those who survived the
shooting
for us it's very painful because we know
that we lost part of ourselves now it
seems the government doesn't care about
us they are not even trying to do
something it's been 10 years now our
lives could have changed for the better
long ago instead our lives have become
worse
[Music]
the government says it wants to finalize
all claims by the end of august but for
those who are reminded of apartheid era
atrocities committed by the government
no amount of money may be enough family
al jazeera johannesburg